2020 sera placée sous le signe du sport
dans les yvelines c'est désormais une
habitude la course paris-nice 2020
s'élancera pour la onzième année
consécutive depuis les yvelines d'après
nos informations les coureurs partiront
le dimanche 8 mars prochain depuis
plaisir pour traverser une partie du
département
le lendemain l'étape partira depuis
chevreuse pour rejoindre le loiret
paris-nice et la course au soleil
c'est la première grande course
internationale de la saison avec tirreno
adriatico et bien sûr la belle et les
meilleurs mondiaux seront au rendez vous
et c'est important d'avoir les plus
grandes les les plus grands coureurs
mondiaux au départ bien sur paris nice
c'est une très très grande course
internationale
le paris nice ne sera pas la seule
course cycliste organisée dans les
yvelines le tour de france passera
également par le département le 19
juillet prochain à mantes la jolie
le peloton s'élancera pour une dernière
étape de 122 kilomètres en direction des
champs elysées
c'est une formidable fête populaire
pendant trois semaines et une dernière
étape qui va traverser une grande partie
des yvelines à partir de menthe
là c'est vraiment quelque chose il y
aura également des courses à pied dans
le département l'une des plus
importantes sera le paris versailles
pour cette 43e édition 25 mille coureurs
s'élanceront 1 27 septembre prochain
depuis la capitale point 16,2 km avant
cette date les yvelines vont accueillir
l'eco trail de paris le 14 mars prochain
l'une des plus longues courses de france
plusieurs centaines de participants vont
s'élancer depuis l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines pour un trail
de 80 km qui les emmènera jusqu'à la
tour eiffel
parmi eux fabien parmentier de montigny
le bretonneux il participera sa 13ème
édition
les principales difficultés on va dire
c'est que c'est très roulant donc il
répétait commettre comme comme étant une
course très roulante c'est à dire sur
laquelle il ya peu de temps de repos on
court beaucoup il n'y a pas forcément
beaucoup de dénivelé il ya 1500 mètres
de dénivelé et donc à partir de là faut
sans cesse être dans la relance et avoir
une bonne bonne gestion de course à
quelques mètres de l'île de loisirs le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines va accueillir pour la première
fois de son histoire un match de volley
ball
la rencontre sera organisée le 28 mars
prochain il devrait opposer des équipes
de première dit
vision saint quentin en yvelines devrait
également accueillir comme tous les ans
depuis 2002 l'open de france de golf le
rendez-vous retrouvera la saison
estivale du 2 au 5 juillet les
organisateurs pourrait néanmoins
délocaliser l'événement dans le sud de
la france
enfin pour les plus courageux le meute
des paris sera organisé les 13 et 14
juin ben
au programme 1 7 et 1 13 km et surtout
beaucoup de goût pour les milliers de
participants